i do freestyle rap that is rap made up
on the spot based entirely on your
suggestions we're gonna get you guys
involved i want you guys to be creative
the best suggestion i ever had was a
german man who said a day in the life of
an aztec high
priest so try and beat klaus from
hamburg okay i want to do better than
that we'll get five suggestions if
you've got one all you got to do put
your hand up my microphone man is going
to run over to you we'll get the
suggestion microphone man bring it down
to this handsome chap in the front
lovely hey what would you like a rap
about my friend i would like you to rap
about uh
apogee playground
i beg your pardon why did you suddenly
go french when you said it you're like
yeah i'd like you to rap about it
yeah it's called apogee playground
apogee playground is that something that
you're involved with exactly that is the
most disgraceful self-promoting startup
attitude i've ever heard of well done
thank you no one else is going to be
allowed to do that you're the only
pray tell what is apogee playground keep
it short this is not a pitch
we are asking people to
turn their work into play turn work into
play with apogee playground if you post
this online you owe me a lot of money
okay
apogee playground turn work into play
let's get our second suggestion hand up
if you got one oh yeah right behind you
perfect sup what would you like a rap
about
baby influencers baby influences thank
you that's perfect let's get our third
suggestion from the lady over there
apogee playground baby influences yes go
for it circular economy
circular a circular pyramid economy oh
economy i think you said a circular
pyramid i was like she's trying to catch
me out i also love that you stood up for
that one and i was like is she gonna
sing is she gonna take over this a
circular economy apogee playground baby
influencers people on this side what
would you like a rap about my man here
busting out of the shirt yes what would
you like a raffle fitness fitness okay
what uh what's your particular favorite
type of fitness
any kind
you're the most boring answer ever yeah
okay i'm not giving you my secrets chris
you've got to work hard to get guns like
these let's get our final suggestion yes
right there right by you
hi krypto please crypto um be more
specific
crypto trading does that help okay no
that's fine yeah cool trading bitcoin
okay crypto trading fitness baby
influences a circular economy an apogee
playground which aims to turn work into
play this lovely people if we can drop
that beat good sir is a freestyle as i
said made up on the spot based entirely
on suggestions not written not prepared
not rehearsed never to be repeated and
do not worry it will not be anywhere
near as atrociously embarrassingly
toe-curlingly bad as you're expecting a
privately educated middle class white
boy to be a little bit more on the b
there my friend less sir let's do
the bass this then we slay that sound i
like the guy who wants the clicks on the
playground at the top that's the apogee
i wrap so naturally i'm basically giving
you an ad for free you gotta make sure
you do it every day we're gonna turn
that work into play admittedly it's
slightly mental in the mind why you
should produce not just leisure time i'm
gonna move on it's how we do i wanna be
circular like number two i talk about
that economy i'm gonna do it properly if
i got the cash and you wanna get it off
of me you gotta make sure you keep
interest i spend that go and reinvest it
goes round keep it like a closed loop
like i'm recycling things here i ask you
this guy
check the arms on him always playing
pump iron when he's there at the gym i
ask for explanation can you charm me
he's like yeah i pump iron like arnie
arnold schwarzenegger and i impress all
of the ladies when i do the fitness i go
there let my gun swell i like to pump
all of that whizzy dumbbells oh so hard
i go berserk i like to twerk in the
mirror when i clean and duck
look at these i'm a big bro probably
investing in crypto i see that body it's
not so strange i like the shape he be
putting it on the exchange maybe get the
bitcoin ethereum or doge if you invest
wisely then it will grow but the last
one i like it oh you're crazy talk about
this i'm an influencer baby i'm on the
insta taking the selfie i'm still in
diapers but i'm gonna get wealthy i get
there i make those moves i'll be making
that cash while i suckle from a boob
it might seem kind of strange to be an
infant but still make that change i say
mom i say dad can you buy me a pacifier
you need to place it that's the plan
i've never seen a baby on instagram
there we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you